c'est une épaisse fumée aux faussaires
de brouillard de guerre
les importants incendies qui touchent
actuellement la californie et l'oregon
ont balayé le cessez le feu lié aux
commémorations du 11-septembre près de 2
millions d'hectares déjà partis en fumée
et sur lesquels les vues des deux
candidats à l'élection présidentielle
dit faire pour le candidat démocrate joe
biden ces gigantesques feux de forêt
sont liés au réchauffement climatique
il dénonce l'inaction de donald trump
sur cette question un cache dans les
ouragans ne dévie pas pour éviter les
états républicains et les états
démocrate
les incendies de forêt ne contourne pas
les villes qui ont voté d'une certaine
manière les impacts du changement
climatique ne se choisissent pas c'est
parce que ce n'est pas un phénomène
partisans c'est de la science si nous
avons encore quatre ans de déni
climatique de trump combien de banlieue
seront brûlées dans les incendies de
forêt combien de quartiers de banlieue
ont été inondées combien de banlieue
auront été emportés par des tempêtes
si vous donnez quatre ans de plus a
rappelé hermann climatique à la maison
blanche
pourquoi serait ton surpris que
l'amérique soit encore en feu
arrivé lundi en californie le locataire
de la maison blanche est tout de suite
montré sceptique sur la question face à
un responsable local de l'agencé de
protection des ressources naturelles de
l'état
ça finira par se refroidir vous allez
voir j'aimerais que la science au
d'accord avec vous je ne pense pas que
la science sache réellement pour le
président américain les coupables
désignés sont avant tout les gouverneurs
démocrates qui n'aurait pas mis en
application les mesures idoines
quand vous avez des années de feuilles
de feuilles sèches par terre ça se
déclenche tout seul c'est vraiment du
combustible pour les feux donc ils
doivent faire quelque chose à ce sujet
ils doivent aussi faire des coupes
les gens n'aiment pas que l'on fasse des
coupes mais ils doivent faire des coupes
donc si vous avez un incendié que ça se
propage vous aurez un espace de 50
mètres au milieu alors ça ne pourra pas
se propager de l'autre côté ils ne font
pas ça un débat qui ont déjà tranché les
climato
og il estime que ces feux sont liées
avant tout aux grandes chaleurs du mois
d'août
couplé à la sécheresse et aux vents
violents des phénomènes liés selon eux
au réchauffement climatique
pour rappel ces incendies ont provoqué
près de 35 morts depuis le début de
l'été et on plaçait portland seattle et
san francisco
parmi les villes les plus polluées du
monde